Bonjour tous le monde, c'est squeezie
Aujourd'hui
Oh putain.., j'ai carrément foiré (Fail..)
Bonjour tous le monde, c'est squeezie
T'as déja entendu ça toi personne as entendu ça...
YO!! Tout le monde c'est squeezie !
Applaudissement..
Hey...Ca va ou pas, moi je m'appelle Kemar
Quand j'arrive sur le dancefloor
tout le monde se met à l'aise...
Ooooooohh, oohhhh
Quand j'arrive sur le dancefloor
tout le monde se met à l'aise...
Regardez le...(rire)
cette pose est incroyable..
la virilitéééé..
Ca vous indique bien la puissance du mec
sur lequel on va tomber
Rires...moqueries
Excellent ca rigole aussi la bas c'est génial
On fait une pose s'il-vous-plait
parce que la c'est trop marrant
Déjà! tu me parle sur un putain de ton!
Ok! sinon je te baise ta gueule
Je vais en prendre pour mon grade
Si vous voyez ce que je veux dire le sous-entendu
Rires....^^
Regarder cette joie sur ce visage de gros porc de no-life
J'ai une facheuse tendance à renifler
Sniff.. Sniff...
Haie cette tête de demon
Celui ci sent particulièrement bon
Ooh !!
c'est quoi ses ondes qui traverse mon corps ?
Aaahh (dégouter)
ok..., ça ça me plait ^^
Naaaa..., arrête de te frotter à moi putain !
Natoo natoo, elle est ou natoo ?
Viens natoo !
Qu'est ce tu fais la, mais casse toi baisse les yeux !
Kitty...Kitty t'es ou ?!
Tu sais pas qui je suis moi ! Ooh!!
Oh la c'est fou, on dirait natoo
C'est bon tu m'as soulé je me casse !
J'ai un peur de ce qui va se passer
je vais demander au gens de s'abonner à ta chaine
puis on va s'arréter la
Tu peux aussi partager cette vidéo
sur ton mur Facebook, alors attention mon p'tit gars
je vais vérifier si tu l'as partagé, alors fais gaffe à toi ^^
Abonne vous à sa chaîne pour le consoler,
sinon vraiment (apeurer..)
merci à tous, je vous aime !
Musique...